, DO YOU KNOW
WHAT IS CRAZY TO ME?
IT IS HOW MUCH AND HOW FAST
TIME FLIES. IT'S ALREADY WEAK 3
. HOW DID YOU DO IN WEEK 2? WAS
IT GOOD, GOOD WEEK.
>> AND KIRK COUSINS IN PRIME
TIME, IT IS THE SAME THING,
LITERALLY THE SAME THING WITH
KIRK COUSINS IN PRIME TIME IS
LITERALLY A NO SHOW.
>> THAT WAS ONE .
THEN YOU KNOW KIRK COUSINS WHEN
OUT THERE AND JUST BEING
HIMSELF.
AND GUYS LIKE MICHAEL RITTER
SAYING TO PUT MDP PLAYS ON KIRK
COUSINS.
>> IT WAS TOUGH.
>> WE'VE GOT TO DO BETTER, BUTT
HAS THE WHOLE SET UP WITH THE
PODCAST AND THE HEADPHONES IN
THE STUDIO, IT MUST BE NICE.
>> I AM READY TO GO IN THE
SHOUT OUT TO THE CREW HERE IN
NEW YORK AND THEY HAVE ME WELL
LIT. WE DON'T HAVE A MONDAY
SHOW, BUT COWBOYS MONEYLINE,
JUST TO LET YOU KNOW AND YEAH,
IT IS NICE HERE.
>>> AND WE ARE PUTTING SAM ON
THE CLOCK THIS WEEK BECAUSE MY
MAN HAS BEEN YAPPING AND WE ARE
PUTTING SAM ON THE CLOCK THIS
WEEK.  YOU CAN KEEP YOUR PICKS
TO 30 SECONDS OR LESS . I
ACTUALLY WANT TO BET ON MATT
RYAN AND I'M TAKING THE OVER.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU AIMING?
>> I HAVE THE OVER AS WELL AND
I HAVE A BELL TO RING FOR HIM
WHEN HE SHOULD SHUT UP. MAYBE
IT IS MY BEST INTEREST TO TAKE
THE UNDER BECAUSE MAYBE I CAN
CONTROL THAT.
>> THAT'S A DELUSION.
>> SAM, YOU ARE ON THE CLOCK
AND ALL EYES ARE ON YOU.  WE
WANT TO KNOW WHAT ARE THE 6th
BEST BETS OF THE WEEK . AND I
GO TO YOU, BROTHER.
>> I START OFF WITH THE COLTS
PLUS 6 AND I GET IT, THEY LOOK
AWFUL.
THE CLASSIC BUY LOW SPOT IN THE
NFL. THEY ARE COMING HOME AND
COULD NOT HAVE LOOKED WORSE.
PEOPLE ARE OVERREACTING SO GIVE
ME 6-POINT AT HOME WITH A GOOD
TEAM.  SINCE I HAVE A 2nd, I
WANT TO SAY YESTERDAY  WAS THE
WORST DAY OF MY LIFE AS A
MIZZOU FOOTBALL FAN.
BOOM.
>> SO WE ARE ROCKING WITH THE
COLTS PLUS 6 AT THE 1st ? SAM,
TALK TO ME, WHAT IS NEXT? YOU
ARE ON THE CLOCK.
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF UGLY
PICKS AND I'M NOT GOING TO LIE
AND I'M SURE I'M GETTING
ROASTED IN THE COMMENTS . IN
THIS LEAGUE YOU BUY LOW AND
SELL HIGH.
BEFORE THAT MASSACRE, IT MAY
HAVE BEEN EAGLES MINUS THREE
NUMBER MINUS 4, BUT YOU HAVE
GOT TO GO AGAINST THAT REACTION
. YOU ARE NOT GOING TO WIN LONG
TERM WITH THREE POINTS EXTRA.
GIVE ME THE SIX-POINT FIVE AND
CARSON WENTZ DOESN'T LOOK THAT
BAD.
MY CLOCK IS UP AND I'M DONE.
>> NOW, TALK TO ME. WHICH WHERE
WE LEANING.
THE PANTHERS LOOKED AWFUL AND
THEY'VE LOST NINE STRAIGHT
GAMES OVERALL. COMING HOME AT 0
AND 2. THEY HAVE TO HAVE IT
STAY ALIVE AND GIVE THEM THE
TWO POINT KNOW AT HOME.
>> IT'S NOT HOT, BUT IT'S ICE
COLD. I MANY GET ROASTED IN THE
COMMENTS AND EVERYONE WILL TELL
ME I'M IN ITALY IT AND THAT'S
WHAT I EXPECT.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M TRYING
TO SAY -- BUT WHAT I AM TRYING
TO SAY IT'S NOT UP TO ME, IT'S
ABOUT THE PEOPLE.
TALK TO US ABOUT WHAT PEOPLE
ARE SAYING IN THE COMMENTS.
ARE IT ARE THEY IN SAM'S FAVOR
OR ROASTING HIM?
>> ONE SAID HIS PICKS WERE NOT
GOOD LAST WEEK, WHY DO WE
LISTEN TO HIM ?
>> THEY WENT 4 INTO SOME.
>> THAT'S WHAT I WAS GOING TO
SAY, 4 AND 2, THAT'S PROFIT.
AND MOVING ON TO, BRENDAN SAYS
THE EAGLES ARE GETTING TOUCHED
TODAY AND I THINK THAT MEANS
YOU LIKE SURE PICK.
AND WE ARE ALL OVER THE
COMMANDERS IN HERE.
AND THE JAGS AND MAGIC
MONEYLINE FOR THE EAGLES. AND
PROBABLY GOING TO MAX OUT THE
COLTS TODAY. HE IS 93% OF THE
PUBLIC WHO IS ALL OVER THE
CHIEFS TODAY.
>> I WOULD LIKE FOR YOU TO
PERSONALLY APOLOGIZE IN THE
COMMENTS AT THE END OF THE SHOW
.
>> AND WE ARE GOING TO WORK ON
THE COMMENTS FOR APOLOGIZING.
BEFORE THAT WE NEED TO WORK ON
THE LAST THREE LEGS OF YOUR
BEST BETS. YOU GAVE IS COLTS
PLUS 6 AND COMMANDERS PLUS SIX-
POINT FIVE. I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THAT SPREAD, BUT LET'S TALK
ABOUT THE LAST THREE. REMEMBER
YOU ARE ON THE CLOCK, BROTHER.
>> THE SAME THING HERE AND WE
GO THE OTHER WAY.
WE LIKE THE DOLPHINS TODAY. I
SENT THIS TWEET AND YOU HAVE TO
READ IT OUT LOUD.
THE BILLS DEFENSE IS COMPLETELY
BEAT UP AND THEY ARE MISSING 4
OR 5 STARTERS.
THAT IS A TOUGH TASK WHEN YOU
ARE GOING AGAINST WADDLE AND
THE DOLPHINS OFFENSE LOOKS
BETTER THAN I EXPECTED. WE ARE
GOING TO SELL HIGH ON THE BILLS
HERE.
>> THERE IT IS. IT MAY BE A
TRACK MEET OUT THERE AND WE
WILL SEE.
LET'S MOVE ON TO YOUR 5th PICK
. SAM.
>> ALL RIGHT, I MAY GET
APPROVAL ON THIS ONE IN
RELATION TO MY OTHERS.
THE TIKI 20 SIXER BEAT UP. IN
WEEKS 1 AND 2 AGAINST THE
COWBOYS MOVING THE BALL,  I
THINK THEY SCORED ONE
TOUCHDOWN.
I LIKE THE PACKERS THIS WEEK
AND I THINK THEY ARE BETTER
THAN THE BUCS . THERE IS A LOT
THAT SCARES ME ABOUT TAMPA BAY
RIGHT NOW.
THEY ARE BEAT UP ON THE
OFFENSIVE LINE AND THEY WOULD
HAVE TO WIN.
>> THEY ARE BEAT UP OUT THERE
AND TAMPA BAY. I DON'T DISLIKE
THAT ONE AT ALL. LEADING TO THE
LAST AND FINAL PICK, TALK TO
ME, SAM, TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING?
>> YOU ARE NOT GOING TO LIKE
THIS ONE. IT'S BRONCOS +1.5.
THE BRONCOS LOOK HORRENDOUS BUT
IN THIS LEAGUE AND IN THIS SPOT
IS WHEN THEY USUALLY SHOW UP. A
PRIME TIME SPOT AT HOME TO SHUT
EVERYONE UP AND GET THE TRAIN
BACK ON THE TRACKS.
THEIR METRICS ARE NOT AS BAD AS
THEIR RESULTS HAVE BEEN AND I
THINK THIS IS A GOOD TEAM AND I
THINK THEY WIN IN A DESPERATION
SPOT AT HOME.
30 SECONDS AND I BEAT YOUR
CLOCK, RYAN.
>> SAM, I DON'T LIKE THAT AND I
WILL BE HONEST.
WHEN THEY GO TO MILE HIGH TODAY
, RYAN, TALK TO ME AND THE
PEOPLE. WHICH WAY ARE THE
PEOPLE LEANING? ARE THEY
LEANING TOWARD MY DECISIONS AND
NOT AGREEING WITH SAM ARE
LEANING THE OTHER WAY AND
RIDING WITH SAM? WHAT ARE THEY
TALKING ABOUT?
>> WE NEED TO KILL THE BAD CUP
VIBES FROM THE LAST SEGMENT.
BIG MIGHT TRUST YOU AND IS
RIDING WITH YOU. AND SMITTY
SAYS HE LIKES THE COLTS PLUS 6
AND IT'S A SOLID LOCK.
ALSO THE DOLPHINS +5.5 IS SOLID.
AND HUNTER SAYS THE COLTS ARE
TRASH AND MICHAEL SAYS YOU ARE
DEAD ON TIME TODAY AND THERE IS
NO GOING OVER THE SHOT CLOCK
AND YOU ARE RIGHT ON IT.
>> I AM IMPRESSED BY ME.
>> AND THE JAGS MAGIC. THE
BILLS DEFENSE IS DEPLETED
WHICH, GOOD POINT, YOU DID SEND
THAT TWEET. AND THE SECONDARY
TODAY IS THE ROOKIE 1st ROUND
PICK ANNA ROOKIE 6th ROUND PICK
. AND HAMLIN WHO IS A 6th ROUND
PICK AND JOHNSON WHO IS A  2019
6th ROUND PICK .
>> THREE TOTAL STARTS BETWEEN
THOSE GUYS AND THEY ARE GOING
TO KEEP UP WITH TYREEK AND
WADDLE?
GOOD LUCK.
>> TELL US WHO YOU ARE BETTING
TO SCORE TODAY. HERE ARE A FEW
TO CHOOSE FROM.
WE ARE GOING TO GO QUICK
THROUGH THIS, SAM. WERE GOING
QUICK THROUGH THIS WITH THE
DRAFTS ON PICK WITH TRAVIS KELTY
KELSEY THE 5th MOST  THAT. AND
JA'MARR CHASE IS THE 4th MOST
BET . HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
JA'MARR CHASE IN THE END ZONE?
THERE HE IS AND JA'MARR CHASE,
DO YOU THINK HE CAN GET IT IN?
>> THIS IS A DESPERATION SPOT
FOR THE BENGALS AND I ASSUME
THEY GO TO THEIR BEST GUY.
I ASSUME IT IS INTERESTING AT
PLUS MONEY.
>> HEY, PLUS MONEY WHICH AMAR
CHASE, I LIKE IT. LET'S MOVE ON
THE JALEN HURTS.
IN THE END ZONE MINUS 110 AND
THE 3rd MOST  BET. AND ALSO ST.
BROWN IS PLUS MONEY TODAY.
+135 AND THE 2nd MOST BET  TO
SCORE TODAY. ROUNDING IT OFF IS
STEFON DIGGS SITTING AT MINUS
110. THAT IS THE MOST BET
TOUCHDOWN SCORE TODAY. SAM, OUT
OF ALL OF THEM, I KNOW YOU
TOUCHED ON JA'MARR CHASE AND
THE PLUS MONEY, BUT OUT OF ALL
OF THOSE GUYS OR ANYBODY IN THE
LEAGUE, WHO GETS INTO THE END
ZONE TODAY?
>> I GET ANYBODY IN THE LEAGUE?
I'M GOING WITH JONATHAN TAYLOR.
I THINK IT'S A GOOD SPOT WHERE
THE COLTS HAVE NOT GOTTEN
TAYLOR AS INVOLVED IN THIS WEEK
THEY NEED TO PLAY BETTER AND
GIVE THEIR BEST PLAYER THE BALL
. I LIKE TAYLOR IN THE END ZONE
TODAY.
>> AND SAM IS ROCKING WITH
JONATHAN TAYLOR.
AND I GO TO TENNESSEE WITH
DERRICK HENRY. I TALKED WEEK
AFTER WEEK ABOUT THE RAIDERS
DEFENSE AND I DON'T SEE
ANYTHING CHANGING. I THINK
DERRICK HENRY WILL BE ABLE TO
RUN THE BALL AND IF THEY GET TO
THE GOAL LINE, WE KNOW THEY
WILL GIVE IT TO DERRICK HENRY
WHICH IS WHAT THEY DID LAST WEEK
. RYAN, TALK TO ME.
YOU'VE GOT MY PICK AND SAM'S
PICK, BUT WHAT DOES THE
AUDIENCE DECIDE?
WHAT ARE THEY PICKING?
>> KP HEARD THE TWEET AND HEARD
THE STAT ON THE SECONDARY AND
LOVES TYREEK AND JAELEN WADDLE.
BIG MIKE LIKES JA'MARR CHASE.
AND DEEBO ON ANYTIME TV. WE HAVE
RAFE L.A.
KAPP WHO LIKES BRANDON. AND
MICHAEL DROPPING INTO THE
COMMENT, CHESTER JEFFERSON IS A
HAMMERLE QUAD DIAMOND LOCK. IT
DOESN'T GET ANYTHING OTHER THAN
THAT.
>> I LIKE IT. LET'S THINK ABOUT
THAT, KIRK COUSINS DIDN'T HAVE
A GOOD GAME LAST WEEK, DO YOU
THINK HE BOUNCES BACK?
>> GUYS, WE PUT TRUST IN KIRK
COUSINS?
I THOUGHT WE DON'T DO THAT ON
THE SHOW.
>> JUSTIN JEFFERSON CAN
OVERCOME KIRK COUSINS.
>> WHAT DOES THE AUDIENCE DECIDE
?
>> WE ARE GALVANIZING AROUND
JUSTIN JEFFERSON.
IT NEEDS TO BE SAID. WE'VE GOT
THE DAVANTE ADAMS AND STEFON
DIGGS BUT THIS IS ADAMS, GUYS.
>> HE IS ON MY FANTASY TEAM AND
I MENTIONED THAT EARLIER IN THE
SHOW.
I LIKE THIS A LOT AND A BIG
BOUNCE BACK AND HOPEFULLY WE
SEND GOOD VIBES INTO THE AIR
FOR A BIG BOUNCE BACK FOR KIRK
COUSINS TODAY. JUSTIN JEFFERSON
INTO THE END ZONE AND THAT WAS
BOOSTED FROM MINUS 160 FIVE TO
+100. A SHOUT OUT TO OUR
FRIENDS AT DRAFTKINGS. IF YOU
WANT TO PARLAY ALL THREE PICKS
WITH MY PICK , SAM'S PICK AND
YOURS, DK WILL BOOST IT BY 25%.
BETTING IN ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN
AND THERE IT IS.
IT IS THE ARE BETTING PAYDIRT
PARLAY. IT'S RIGHT THERE ON
DRAFTKINGS AND YOU CAN GO GET IT
.
>>> NOW IT'S TIME FOR MY
FAVORITE PART OF THE SHOW, SAM.
LAST WEEK, LAST WEEK WE WERE
CLOSE.
>> WHAT HAPPENED? WHAT HAPPENED
?
>> I DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
IT, BUT I WILL.
>> THE PAST IS IN THE PAST, GO
AHEAD.
>> THE INDIANAPOLIS COLTS DID
NOT SHOW UP BUT THAT'S OKAY
BECAUSE WE ARE BACK.
WE ARE GOING TO DO AND EIGHT
LEG PARLAY AND WE WILL SEE THIS
ONE GO IN. SAM, I WILL GET US
STARTED WITH THE 1st PICK .
ACTUALLY, LET'S BRING UP RYAN,
1st PICK  IS THE KANSAS CITY
CHIEFS PLUS SIX-POINT FIVE.
I THINK THAT WAS GOING TO BE IT.
SAM, YOUR TAKE WITH KANSAS CITY
PLUS SACKS AND A HALF.
I LIKE IT . MOVING ON TO THE
MIAMI DOLPHINS AT 17 1/2
AGAINST THE BILLS. YOU ARE
TAKING IT WITH THE BILLS, SO I
LIKE IT. LET'S MOVE ALONG. THE
DETROIT LIONS +20.5. I DON'T
THINK THE VIKINGS IS GOING TO
GO BLOW THEM OUT, SO I COULD
SEE THE LIONS KEEPING THAT ONE
CLOSE. NOW, THE LAS VEGAS
RAIDERS. I DON'T REALLY LIKE TO
BET ON THE LAS VEGAS RAIDERS,
BUT, YOU KNOW, IN THIS
SITUATION I'M TAKING THE
RAIDERS +10 1/2 POINTS AGAINST
THE TITANS. THEY DON'T IMPRESS
ME WITH RYAN TANNEHILL AS THE
QUARTERBACK.
>> IT MAKES ME HAPPY TO SEE
RYAN SCROLL ALL THE WAY DOWN. I
MISS THAT WITH HIM SCROLLING TO
THE BOTTOM FOR PLUS 20 1/2
THAT'S AND YOU CAN'T BEAT IT.
>> IT'S MY FAVORITE PART OF THE
SHOW.
>> AND LET'S FIND THE
JACKSONVILLE JAGUARS BECAUSE I
WANT YOU TO SCROLL. AND THEN
THE ALTERNATE SPLIT SPREAD TO
+15 POINT FIVE. THAT IS WHAT WE
ARE LOCKING IN AGAINST THOSE
CHARGERS AND I LIKE IT.
MOVING ON, RYAN, FIND ME THE
ARIZONA CARDINALS TAKING ON THE
RAMS.
RAMS IN A DIVISION MATCHUP.
>> SCROLL, SCROLL, SCROLL.
>> THAT IS PERFECT FOR WHAT WE
ARE TRYING TO DO.
THE DIVISION MATCHUP. SHOULD IT
BE A CLOSE GAME? GO TO ARIZONA
CARDINALS AND SCROLL DOWN TO
17, PLEASE. ACTUALLY, IT'S AT
THE TOP. WE ARE BETTING ON THIS
TO BE A CLOSE ONE. AND MOVING
ON TO THE SAN FRANCISCO 49ers
AND THE DENVER BRONCOS.
JIMMY GAROPPOLO AND RUSSELL
WILSON.
>> ARE YOU WORRIED THIS IS PLUS
MONEY TERRITORY? THAT IS PRETTY
RISKY.
>> SAM, BELIEVE IN THE
APPROACH, BROTHER. WE ARE
ALMOST THERE LAST WEEK. WE WERE
ALMOST THERE. WHEN WE SEE THIS
ONE THAT CATCHES, BE ON OUR
BEDDING AND INSTAGRAM PLATFORMS
AND TIKTOK. WE ARE GOING TO
CELEBRATE. DID YOU FIND THE
49ers? SCROLL ALL THE WAY DOWN,
PLEASE AND LOOK FOR +10.5. LOCK
THAT ONE IN FOR ME. I DON'T SEE
THE NINERS LOSING BY MORE THAN
10 POINTS. AND LAST BUT NOT
LEAST --
>> I THOUGHT WE WERE GOING
COWBOYS MONEY LINE.
>> LAST BUT NOT LEAST, THE
COMMANDERS.
>> LET'S GO WITH OUR COMMANDERS
.
>> THERE IT IS. RYAN, ARE THEY
AT THE TOP WITH +20?
>> YES, THEY ARE.
>> ALL RIGHT, LOCK THAT ONE IN.
>> JUST THE SERIOUSNESS ON
GREG'S'S FACE AS HE GIVES OUT
THE COMMANDERS +20, I LOVE IT.
>> ALL RIGHT, SCROLL SO WE CAN
SEE NOT THE SLIP, BUT THE SKIP.
I WILL READ IT ALL FROM THE TOP
REALLY QUICK.
ALL RIGHT, HERE WE GO.
ARE YOU READY? LET'S GET RIGHT
TO IT. THE CHIEFS PLUS SIX-
POINT FIVE. THE MIAMI DOLPHINS
+17.5. AND THE LAS VEGAS
RAIDERS PLUS 10 1/2.
THE JACKSONVILLE JAGUARS +15
POINT FIVE. THE CARDINALS AT +17
AND THE SAN FRANCISCO 49ers AT
+10 1/2 AND THE WASHINGTON
COMMANDERS OF +20. LOCK THAT
ONE AND THEN WE SEE A WIN TODAY
AND WE TURN THE TIDE. MAKE SURE
YOU GET IN ON DRAFTKINGS AND
LOCK THAT ONE IN.
>> YOU CAN SEE IN REAL TIME
THERE I WAS POINTING DOWN AND
THE LINE IS MOVING.
EVERYONE IS WATCHING THE SHOW
AND GOING TO BUILD THIS BET AND
HAMMERING IT.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE A REAL TIME.
THE COMMANDERS +20 IS INCREDIBLE
. NO METEORS THIS WEEK.
>> I'M JUST TRYING TO WIN, MAN,
I'M JUST TRYING TO WIN. IF WE
ARE FINDING STRATEGIES TO WIN
MONEY FROM THE CASINO AND WE
FIGURE OUT WAYS TO DO IT, WHY
NOT?
WHY NOT BUILD THE PARLAY AND
TRY TO GET SOME MONEY FROM THE
CASINO?
THAT'S WHY YOU ARE HERE AND WHY
WE ARE HERE AND THAT'S WHAT WE
ARE TRYING TO DO. NOW LET'S
MOVE ONTO OVER AND UNDER. SAM,
THE TOP FIVE MOST BET PLAYER
PROPS ON DRAFTKINGS.
LET'S START WITH THE 5th ONE
WITH LAMAR JACKSON OVER AND
UNDER AND IT'S SITTING AT +105.
AND REVEALING AT THE SAME TIME,
SAM, 3, 2, 1.
>> I LOVE THAT.
SAM, TALK TO ME, ARE YOU GOING
OVER WITH A GAME LAST WEEK?
>> I'M ALL IN ON LAMAR JACKSON
THIS WEEK.
I THINK HE IS GOING TO WIN MVP
AND I THINK HE IS ON THE
WARPATH.
I AM TAKING HIM.
>> AND DEREK CARR OVER OR UNDER
WITH PASSING TOUCHDOWNS?
I DON'T KNOW WHICH ONE I WILL
GO WITH THIS ONE.
3, 2, 1.
>> OH.
>> SAM, WHY UNDER?
>> THEY ARE 0 AND 2 AND DEREK
CARR IS THROWING THE BALL A LOT
. THIS IS THE WEEK WHERE THEY
HAVE LOST TWO GAMES IN A ROW
AND I THINK HE GETS FALTERED IN
THE RED ZONE IMPROBABLY THROWS
ONE TOUCHDOWN.
>> AND JACOBS IS QUESTIONABLE
AND THAT'S WHY I AM LEANING
TOWARDS DEREK CARR.
>> AND JOE BURROW SITTING AT
MINUS 170.  THIS IS THE 3rd
MOST BET AT DRAFTKINGS . LET'S
REVEAL ON 3. 1, 2, 3.
>> I MEAN, HE'S GOT TO HIT THIS
ONE, RIGHT?
>> HE'S GOT TO HIT IT.
>> ENOUGH SAID.
>> PRODUCER RYAN, WHAT IS GOING
ON AND WHAT ARE THEY TALKING
ABOUT?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT KB GIANTS
MEANS BY THIS BUT HE SAYS
YOU'RE PARLAY LOOKS LIKE A WAWA
SANDWICH.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANYTHING
BETTER, BUT WITH REGARDS TO THE
OVER AND UNDER, BIG MIKE SAYS
OVER FOR SURE.  AND ALSO ON THE
OVER FOR LAMAR  WITH 250 YARDS
AND 3+ TOUCHDOWNS. AND ALL OVER
DEREK CARR  WHICH IS OVER. AND
HE WINS HIGH AND ON THE UNDER
FOR DEREK CARR BECAUSE JOSH
JACOBS SEEMS HE IS PLAYING . WE
ARE NOT REALLY SURE, YET ON THAT
. HE TRAVELED SEPARATELY FROM
THE TEAM BUT ON THE UNDER
BECAUSE OF THAT.
>> HEY, THERE IT IS.
SAM, WE'VE GOT A COUPLE OF MORE
TO GO THROUGH.
PRODUCER RYAN TO GO THROUGH AND
HOPEFULLY THE COMMENTS ARE
STILL FILLING UP WITH GOOD
VIBES.
JOSH ALLEN OVER OR UNDER SITTING
AT MINUS 220.  THE 2nd MOST BET
ON DRAFTKINGS AND I THINK WE
AGREE ON THIS ONE , BUT LET'S
SEE, MAYBE NOT. WE DON'T KNOW.
3, 2, 1.
>> I'M SORRY, I WENT TOO QUICK.
IT IS A LITTLE SCARY BUT HE'S
GOING TO THROW TWO TOUCHDOWNS,
JOSH ALLEN.
>> IT IS JOSH ALLEN IN 2022.
AND HERE WE GO WITH MY FANTASY
QUARTERBACK. ONE OF MY FAVORITE
QUARTERBACKS IN THE LEAGUE NOT
ON THE SAN FRANCISCO 49ers.
OVER 2.5 TOUCHING TOUCHDOWNS.
I THINK YOU KNOW WHICH WAY I'M
LEANING.
LET'S DO IT AT 3, 2, 1.
>> COLTS?
>> THE COLTS SHUT DOWN THE
CHIEFS. THEY COVER THE SIX-
POINT'S AND HE IS THROWING TWO
TOUCHDOWNS THIS WEEK.
>> TWO TOUCHDOWNS FOR MY MAN SAM
. GOING UNDER 3 AND I DON'T
KNOW HOW I FEEL ABOUT THAT ONE.
IT'S OKAY WITH THE BEST TWEETS
OF THE WEEK UP NEXT.
MY MAN, PRODUCER RYAN, GIVE US
SOME GOOD VIBES.
WHAT WERE SOME OF THE BEST
TWEETS OF THIS PAST WEEK THAT
YOU HAVE ACCUMULATED?
>> I GOT THIS FROM YOU, GREG. I
GOT THIS FROM YOU. THE 49ers
MONEY LINE WITH ALL THE ASSETS
ON IT?
>> ALL THE ASSETS. EVERYTHING
YOU'VE GOT. 401(K) AND YOUR
SAVINGS ACCOUNT. YOUR MOM'S
SAVINGS ACCOUNT, PUT EVERYTHING
ON IT. THE DENVER BRONCOS AND
THEIR OFFENSE OF COORDINATOR
AND DEFENSIVE COORDINATOR ARE
ALL IN POSITIONS THEY'VE NEVER
DONE BEFORE. THEY HAVE LOOKED
DISCOMBOBULATED THE LAST TWO
WEEKS AND I DON'T THINK THAT
WILL CHANGE.
THE 49ers KNOW HOW TO RUN THE
BALL AND I THINK I GET THE W IN
DENVER. THERE IT IS.
>> THIS NEXT ONE IS FOR YOU,
SAM, AND WE ARE STAYING ON
TOPIC.
>> AND HACKETT MAY BE
GENERATIONAL IN THE ONE TO WATCH
.
>> HE HAS BEEN THE WORST COACH
OF THE SEASON SO FAR, BUT HE
HIRED LIKE A GAME SPECIALIST
INTO THIS WEEK TO HELP WITH
TIME MANAGEMENT DECISIONS. HE
HAS TAKEN IT OUT OF HIS HANDS
AND HE HAS A CLEAR MIND AND THE
BRONCOS GET IT DONE.
>> YOU ARE REALLY BETTING ON
SOMEBODY THAT HAD TO DO THAT
MIDSEASON?
>> YOU'VE GOT TO LEARN FROM
YOUR MISTAKES AND THAT IS
CALLED GROWTH.
I LOVE IT.
>> THAT IS GROWTH, THAT IS
GROWTH, BUT THAT'S CRAZY.
>> I CAN'T WAIT UNTIL THE
MELTDOWN TONIGHT DURING SUNDAY
MIGHT FOOTBALL WHEN SAM ASKED
HIMSELF WHY HE BET ON NATHANIEL
HACKETT.
>> WE WILL PUT THIS OUT LATER
WHEN THE BRONCOS ARE UP 24-0.
>> 24-0, WOW!
.
>> THEN WE HAVE MICHAEL RITTER
AND I PERSONALLY HAVE A BEEF
WITH THIS.
IF HE COULD, HE WOULD CHOOSE TO
LIVE IN PHILADELPHIA WITH HOW
MUCH HE LOVES PHILADELPHIA
SPORTS.
THE EAGLES BLOWOUT KIRK COUSINS
AND HIS VIKINGS AND ALL THE
SUDDEN HE REVERTS TO AND
UNDEFEATED SEASON FOR THE
EAGLES AND TWEETS OUT THERE
SCHEDULE. GIVE ME YOUR THOUGHTS
ON THIS AND ALSO IN EAGLES
RECORD PREDICTION.
>> WHY.
>> THAT'S AND OVERREACTION FOR
SHARE AND THEY ARE GOING TO
LOSE GAMES THIS YEAR AND NOT GO
17 AND 0. THEY DO HAVE AND EASY
SCHEDULE, I WILL GIVE THEM THAT
, IT'S A VERY EASY SCHEDULE AND
THEY ARE GOING TO WIN GAMES. I
WOULD SAY THEY LOSE TODAY. THE
COMMANDERS UPSET THEM AT HOME.
I'M JUST GOING WITH ALL MY
PICKS WITH THE COMMANDERS
UPSETTING THEM AT HOME . NOW WE
ARE AT WEEK 11 AND THEY DON'T
PLAY THE COLTS TWO WEEKS FROM
NOW, BUT THAT IS A DECENT TOUGH
STRETCH RIGHT THERE AROUND WEEK
11 OR 12.
>> THEY ONLY GO AS FAR AS THE
QUARTERBACK TAKES THEM AND LAST
WEEK HE LOOKED REALLY, REALLY
GOOD.
HE LOOKED GOOD, BUT WILL THAT
CONTINUE THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
WITH THE ADJUSTMENTS TEAM IS
GOING TO MAKE?
WE WILL SEE. I DON'T KNOW, WE
WILL SEE ABOUT THIS EAGLES
TEAM.
>> THEY ARE 2 AND 0 RIGHT NOW
IN MY PREDICTION IS 2 AND 15.
AND I'M UNBIASED.
>> ALL RIGHT, GUYS, DRAFT YOUR
PICKS IN THE CHAT AND WE WILL
GRADE THEM. MAN SAM CAN GIVE
OUT SOME GRADES BECAUSE THEY'VE
BEEN GIVING US SHADE. YOU KNOW,
THEY'VE BEEN GIVING US GOOD
VIBES AND SHADE AND NOW IT IS
TIME FOR ME AND SAM TO RETURN
THE FAVOR AND GIVE THEM GRADES
ON THEIR PICK.
>> AND TO THE GUY WHO TOLD ME
MY PICKS SUCKS , I'M JUST CAN
AUTOMATICALLY GIVE HIM ENOUGH
KICK.
JUST KIDDING.
>> PARIS THINKS THE NINERS ARE
GOING TO WARP THE BRONCOS
TONIGHT.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHERE GREG IS
GOING WITH THAT.
>> [ LAUGHTER ].
>> I COULD KEEP ADDING PLUSES.
>> AND THE DOLPHINS MONEY LINE,
FORGET THE POINTS AND GO WITH
THE MONEY LINE.
>> I GET SCARED AND ALWAYS TAKE
THE SPREAD, BUT I REALLY DO
LIKE THE DOLPHINS.
YEAH, I LIKE THAT.
>> ONE MORE AND THEN WE ARE OUT
OF HERE.
>> AND SAM SAYS I'M A HATER OF
THE EAGLES AND I AM.
AND THE BOND THEY ITEMS ADAMS
WITH ONE TOUCHDOWN.
>> THAT'S THE WRONG CARD, I
MEANT TO GIVE A B AND I GRABBED
A C.
>> I GIVE IT A B+.
>> ABE PLUS AND MINUS GUY, I
NEED TO ADD THAT.
>> RENFRO IS OUT AND HE'S ON MY
FANTASY TEAM TOO. YOU KNOW WHAT
THEY DO IN LAS VEGAS, THEY FEED
HIM. GUYS, IT HAS BEEN FUN. WE
GRADED THE CHAT AND THEY GRADED
US. WE GOT PRODUCER RYAN
INVOLVED IN THE SHOW AND I LOVE
HIS SET UP. I'M JUST SO, SO
JEALOUS.
>> WHY DON'T WE GET THAT?
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
>> WE HAVE SAM CONSISTENTLY
DRINKING WATER THROUGHOUT THE
SHOW.
>> I'M WATCHING FOOTBALL FOR
THE NEXT 12 HOURS AND I NEED TO
HYDRATE.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO HYDRATE AND
HOPEFULLY YOUR HYDRATED BEFORE
THIS NFL SUNDAY AS WELL. BEFORE
WE GET OUT OF HERE WITH THE
49ers MONEY LINE.
MY NAME IS GREG IVEY & RICHARD
AND PRODUCER RYAN, PEACE.